[Music]
all right people
it is november 9th 2020
and i'm dave rubin this is the reuben
report direct message
there's a lot going on in the world
right now and we're gonna hit
as much of it that i think perhaps you
need to know as possible
but again not gonna depress you around
here i don't think i'm gonna try not to
depress you we'll see what happens
uh okay so first i want to talk just
sort of
broadly about the mental state of
most people that that i'm seeing at the
moment um
of course i guess before i get to that
specifically i should give you a mini
update that has something to do with
reality as far
as the election which is that the ap
and some news outlets have called it but
the election results
obviously aren't certified and that
trump is going to challenge things now i
think anyone regardless of whether
you wanted trump to win or you wanted
biden to win
or whatever you wanted joe jorgensen or
kanye west
i think that most people most sane
people in a democracy would say
that they want uh the election to feel
that it was honest and real and
everything else so if right now your
position
is that it was legit and it's good and
we're good to go then you let trump do
his legal challenges and they won't work
out and everything's fine so
i think having everyone considering
that it sounds like about 74 million
people
assuming it's real voted for biden in
about 71
voted for trump this is a this is a huge
amount of people that voted
trump if in fact he lost got the second
most votes
all time only to biden which all seems
very bizarre
but the point is that i think what's
more important than who
won specifically in a bizarre sense is
that if we're to believe that this
system works then you have to
let the system do what it does so trump
is allowed to
to challenge in courts to find out
what's going on and if things are within
margins of error or they trigger
recounts or all that then all of that
process will happen
and and if at the end he loses he loses
and if if something gets reversed he
gets reversed
but i think everyone's popping the
champagne on the left a little
too quickly and and that they've sort of
just jumped into this
i guess this thing where it's like we're
already telling you who's in our
administration we're already telling you
we're putting critical race theory back
into
into the government i mean all of these
things that that seem pretty bizarre
uh to be just so quickly jumping in on
on top of the fact that
this campaign staffer for pete bootage
has started this ridiculous trump
accountability thing where they're gonna
just start listing people who have
anything to do
with the with the campaign and with the
administration and it's like that's
that's actually the most anti-american
thing you know coming up with these
lists so we can make sure what
that these people don't have jobs in the
future or that they can't get bank
accounts or they can't be on social
media
i mean in a bizarre sense these people
are actually everything that they
purported trump to be all these years
anyway
so before i get into just sort of some
personal stuff
and what's going on right now i just
wanted to say that that i am completely
okay
dave rubin here i am completely okay
with everyone doing whatever
legal mechanism they have and then at
the end once those things have been
exhausted obviously we have a president
it's as simple as that but i think that
there is a just a little bit
of premature celebration here like we
you know and and by the way i am hearing
some sane people say that not not too
many people saying people
are saying that but but some people are
out there um so before i get into some
of the nitty gritty of what's happened
in the last couple days
i wanted to talk about just sort of like
the general state of being
because i can tell you that regardless
of what happens here let's say biden
wins
like my general state of being although
it would not have been my choice and in
many ways
i'll have to fight harder right for the
things that i believe in free speech
and open inquiry and the american dream
and capitalism and all that well hey i
like fighting
in some ways i think i probably like
being in an opposition more than
in the power right like i'm not i'm not
that concerned with power i like
fighting for what i believe in
and i'm actually okay with that um but
what i've noticed is there's a lot of
people that you can sense that their
whole outlook on life just got
completely flipped and and i think that
that's dangerous
it's dangerous for many reasons and it's
one of the reasons why you should never
want
a president that has so much power that
your
whole life outlook your whole
existential
being can be changed depending on who
the president is
so it's like these people who have been
miserable and screaming and hysterical
and hitler and nazis they're coming for
us and everything else
for the last four years suddenly they're
out in the park and they're dancing and
they're celebrating everything else i
just want to give you two personal
examples of things that have happened to
me just over this this past weekend now
again
i'm not thrilled with what the purported
results
at the moment but i will accept
democratically elected results i'm not
the king
right so it is what it is and as i said
trump has every right to challenge
however
he wants to challenge okay uh i have
i'll tell you
two things so i have a a friend who goes
back a long time
um and we've sort of lost touch over the
last couple of years because he
he's a lefty i am what i am whatever you
want to call that at this point
and over the years when we've had we've
had political debates for 20 plus years
about all sorts of stuff and it was
never
hostile like it could always just at the
end it was like all right let's
let's have a beer or whatever it is but
during the trump years
when i tried to have these conversations
with him it would get extremely hot
uh angry and you know i'm defending a
bigot and all of this stuff
to the point that at one time we were at
a we were at a bar in new york city
and we were sitting there and he's
really yelling at me and all this
craziness and i hadn't seen him for
for quite some time he's getting very
hostile and he had just had a kid
and i wanted to talk about the kid now
his wife's doing and everything else but
he had to bring everything back to
politics
and it just wouldn't i couldn't end it i
couldn't end it and you know me like i
will do everything i can
to to defray these situations right so i
finally said to him
do you think it's possible that i
believe what i believe
as much as you believe what you believe
and he immediately said no
like without even having to think about
it like i could not possibly believe the
things that i'm saying
he is so earnest and honest and
forthright and i'm the reverse of that
and i know many of you have these types
of examples where you get into debates
with people and they
they can't even begin to believe that
you might believe these things anyway
it can't it continued to escalate and
i've actually never done this in my
entire life before and i hope i never
have to do it again
but i just threw money down at the bar
we were sitting at the bar and i left
um anyway we haven't really talked much
in the last two years but then on
saturday night uh he texted me a picture
of us from years ago
no no comment just a just a picture of
us and i thought
this is this is so absolutely
why the obsession with politics is
making everyone crazy
so you believe that you got the result
you wanted so we haven't been able to
talk for these last couple years and
whatever and i'm
this awful person and everything else
but now that you've got the result
here's a little reminder
that we're friends we can be friends
again we can be friends again
and i'll have to figure out how i want
to deal with that personally in my own
in my own life and i do try to extend
the olive branch as much
as possible but i had that happen and
then yesterday
i was talking to another friend who has
had major
you know trump derangement stuff and the
world's ending and everything else
um and we were talking on facetime
actually and he said to me in the middle
of it and we weren't really talking
about politics like so specifically we
were talking a little bit about covet
and
whatever else and kind of about life and
he said to me
um you know you should smile more
now first off i i think people always
say to me when i'm talking i look like
i'm smiling so i think i generally do
smile a lot
although i don't think whether you smile
a lot or not it's necessarily indicative
of
anything else you can smile you know joe
biden smiles it's a little scary you
know what i mean
so putting aside smiles specifically i
thought it was really interesting
because here's
another friend who has had massive trump
derangement syndrome the
the country is ending the world is
ending koben's going to kill all of us
just all the stuff that you know about
now they got the result that we wanted
and they're telling me to smile more
even though i haven't seen them smile
in years like it's this sort of uh
asymmetry of things where if your whole
world is wrapped up in politics
the same people who four years ago
didn't want us to accept results are now
demanding we accept results with no
questions
um this this is dangerous and weird
and i don't like it and i just wanted to
mention that up top because even though
i talk about
these political things that all sort of
feel separate from the human part like i
thought
if i framed a little of this in the
human part i thought that might be good
anyway let's
go to some video here because this is
just incredible folks
biden you know announced the winner by
the media again it's not certified okay
that's fine
um and then it's just incredible because
remember when trump was having all of
these events
because biden didn't really have any
events or campaign or anything still got
73 million votes
incredible um but when when trump was
having all these events these were super
spreader events
and you know nobody's wearing masks and
they're packing all these people in and
they're not social distancing and kobe
is going to kill all of us
well let's look at some video of the
last couple days what the people
uh who have been telling us to stay
locked down and not do anything in the
world's coming to an end let's take a
look at what they're up to now
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
well
well there you've got it guys we've
solved kobid's social distancing not
necessary anymore you don't necessarily
have to wear masks anymore
you can win an election and then also
burn down effigies of the guy that you
just defeated the
i saw a lot of tweets something like
this we've we've gotten rid of the
dictator
elect with through elections
uh yeah there's just there's just so
much hypocrisy all over the place and
these people have been doing this
relentlessly
and the mainstream media of course
refuses to call them out and they'll
never call them out we know that when
when there were black lives matter
rallies with thousands of people the
media wouldn't say that had anything to
do
with spreading covid but if trump had
rallies it was all about that and
and the rest of it um i also want to
talk a little bit
about some of the hypocrisy related to
um
accept sort of this accept the results
and we have to unify now because i'm
we're hearing a lot about this that we
have to accept the results now i already
talked about that at some level
it's like the same people who didn't
accept the results for four years are
now telling us to accept the results
again i say this within the framework of
if they if they do whatever they are
gonna do in terms of lawsuits and
everything else and we have a result and
it
feels right and everything then okay it
is what it is you don't always win all
the elections okay
so be it um but these are the same
people who for four years ran with the
russian collusion hoax and then an
impeachment
and the rest of it that never accepted
the legitimacy of the election that
that actually in many cases were trying
to burn down the system the entire time
now they got what they wanted so we have
to accept it okay that's fine and i get
the hypocrisy thing
and so be it um the part that's more
interesting to me
is this now we have to heal part now we
have to heal
now let's try it the other way because
we're hearing the heal thing out of out
of biotin and all the demerits now is
the time to heal
now is the time to bring the country
together we've apparently purged racism
and all of these things
now that kind of sounds right right like
i listen to biden's speech and it's sort
of if you're not really thinking it does
sort of sound right
and would we all like a healing of the
nation well i can't say we would all
like it but would most people like the
healing of the nation meaning
meaning that we weren't at each other's
throats all the time that the tenor
and the and the tone was was down a
little bit the flame was a little bit
lower
i think most people would like that but
but it's very bizarre coming from these
people
who for four years they didn't have what
they wanted right so the rest so we were
bigots and racists and everything else
now they believe they have what they
wanted so now is the time
to heal but think about it this way
let's pretend
that the results had come in the other
way the the
trump had won again when you say results
it's a little murky right now
but let's just say trump had one do you
think any of these people would be
saying now is the time to heal
now is the time to reach out across the
aisle no they would literally be
screaming burned down but
but not only screaming burned down they
would actually be burning it down
let's not forget there's no riots right
now well that's not quite true
there are antifa and black lives matter
riots in portland and seattle and there
were some in dc and in new york where
they just generally want to destroy
you know america those are just you know
just the general those things but there
aren't mass
riots of people not accepting the
results or whatever it might be
there was no chance that trump
supporters were going to be out there
destroying businesses and attacking
people and the rest of it
there just wasn't and the mainstream
media offered you up
50 50 guys we're boarding up everything
i mean i'm here in los angeles every
freaking thing is still boarded up it's
like
50 50. if trump wins then we know
they're going to do it and if biden wins
we know they're going to do it and it
and it just isn't true and i think what
you're going to see
is an incredible amount of gas lighting
i'm using the phrase properly
a tremendous amount of gaslighting over
the next couple weeks
the same people who would have gladly
destroyed everything if they didn't get
what they wanted
will now basically make it seem like oh
they're they're just so good they're so
good and they're so right
and the rest of it so it's it's going to
be a little bit messy and as always i
will i will try to give it to you in
in some kind of honest way um but let's
talk about the the kobit situation for a
second
because magically you're not gonna
believe this guys pfizer
uh last night or early this morning uh
announced that they have a vaccine that
is
90 effective in the first analysis just
out of nowhere we just got biden a
couple days ago and now
pfizer is saying this the world is a
strange place
allow me to uh read a little bit about
it for you
pfizer and bioentech said in a joint
statement that their preliminary
findings have shown higher success rates
than many had expected people who
received two doses as part of the trial
saw
90 fewer symptomatic cases of copin 19
than participants who were given a
placebo now what i find interesting
about that quote specifically
is 90 fewer symptomatic cases
but we've also been told constantly to
watch out for the asymptomatic cases and
in many
cases we've been told you have to watch
out for those more because
you may be completely asymptomatic and
getting other people sick
so when they're saying this 90 thing
well i would want to know well how many
people are asymptomatic and everything
else but without
without whittling down the numbers on
this it's just it's just
fairly obvious i'm not a conspiracy
theorist
i'm really not um but i think you are
allowed to
not allowed i think you should actually
um explore the different venues
of when you get information why did i
get this information now how did i get
the information who's sending me the
information and everything else
so the timing seems a little bizarre uh
if it's real
i suppose it's fantastic but we shall
see it and i think this asymptomatic
part is
is a little bit bizarre um but either
way i think what you're going to see is
more and more people will be out and
about
let's also remember that in new york
city right now
so there's videos of literally thousands
and thousands of people
uh in brooklyn and in in some of the
other boroughs and they're out there and
they're celebrating and they're dancing
and they're playing
music these people who again five days
ago they thought that
we were in the third reich uh they're
now they're now thrilled about
everything
but keep in mind you cannot go to church
or temple
in new york city you cannot go to church
or temple in los angeles
so that means what what de blasio is
saying in new york city
and cuomo who is just that he's the only
guy worse than andrew cuomo is his
brother chris cuomo that that's tough
and by the way i really like their dad
mario cuomo who was the
the governor of new york years ago you
know 30 years ago
um but the idea here is okay you guys
can be out in the park and you don't
have to social distance and many people
weren't wearing masks and you can
celebrate and it's all fine and the
media won't say a word about it and
everything else and we're not going to
arrest you
nothing like that but if you go to
church if you go to temple
if you try to open up your small store
if you try to open up your restaurant
well now you're in trouble and even in
the last two days there were some videos
going around
of of you know these middle management
regulators these these
little these little people who have far
more in common with the nazis actually
than anyone else who just show up at
these
places of business and try to shut
people down and it
and this type of hypocrisy this is what
we're gonna have to be on the
on the lookout for more than anything
else um
and and and one other thing related to
this which is that
i definitely think that no matter what
happens
going forward that our ability to
communicate on social media is going to
be deeply deeply
hampered right like the the simple fact
is the only thing that was keeping big
media not from going completely all in
on censorship and everything else is
that there was some threat
from the administration well once that
threat is gone
and now we already know the critical
race theory if biden is the president is
going back into the system
and what that means is that anyone who
argues with these ideas will be labeled
a racist i mean that's how
brilliant you have to admire the alien
like quality of the
totality of these ideas it's so insane
um
but why wouldn't what phrase it
differently why would
social media allow for the 70 million
people who are going to be deemed racist
by the political establishment the media
establishment
and big tech why would it let them on
these platforms and then i think you can
extrapolate a million questions
beyond that so i think that we are going
to see all sorts of weird censorship and
and all sorts of weird stuff which by
the way
is why i always tell you guys if you
want to communicate with me directly
join us on
on reubenreport.com and we're troll free
and we're bot free and it's a and it's a
gated community a small community
it's not so small but it's it's our
small community and that's what i think
the future
of the internet is i don't think it's
these giant big tech platforms i simply
don't
um okay but let's let's move on to uh to
the final story because i've been
talking about
sort of this this hypocrisy
related to okay let's let's reach out
across the aisle now let's let's heal
and all that well
that's what a lot of people are saying
but not jennifer rubin of the washington
post and before i go any further
about jennifer rubin same spelling i
want to be very clear about something
i've never been
more clear about anything in my life i
am not related to jennifer rubin
i don't know jennifer rubin i've never
celebrated a holiday with jennifer rubin
i don't
want to know her in any way and it's
very odd to me that she's
part of this system this is a person who
says she's a conservative
but i don't know what conservative uh
idea she holds
nor has helped any conservative cause
but you know they they love her on the
left because she says she's a
conservative and thus
destroys conservatism from within this
is sort of a little bit
like the the project lincoln guys or the
lincoln project guys whatever the hell
they are just go away already people
anyway jennifer rubin was on msnbc that
wonderful bastion
of journalism that that fantastic place
that's going to tell you as it is
and she had this to say about the future
of conservatism and the future of the
republican party
um it's not only that trump has to lose
but that all his enablers have to lose
they have to we have to collectively in
essence burn down the republican party
um we have to level them because if
there are survivors if there are people
who
weather this storm they will do it again
they will take this as confirmation that
hey
it just pays to ride the waves look at
me i made it through
and so up and down the ticket federal
state
local offices the country has to
repudiate this it
is not a normal administration and when
these people say oh you can't criticize
us
it will deter public service it will
deter people who are
liars who are enablers um who are
really bad people and i
dave rubin am not related
to jennifer rubin i want to be very
clear about that as a matter of fact we
will clip me
saying this right now and i will share
it across the internet for all time
i dave rubin i'm not
related to jennifer rubin do you
understand
okay let's unpack what miss jennifer
rubin said there because there's so much
to it
these people these people are not
fit for polite society now i don't even
know what polite society is anymore and
i'm not even sure that i would want to
be part of it
at this point but these people meaning
people who believe
different things than her people who
vote a different way than her they're
not
fit for polite society here's here's
just a spectacular quote
i think it's absolutely abhorrent that
any institution of higher learning
any news organization and or any
entertainment organization that has a
news outlet would hire these people
so what's she in effect what she's
saying is
if you're on the right if you're one of
the 70 million people
who voted for donald trump because she's
not you know their friend you know
they'll frame it as oh we mean the
people that work in the administration
or something like that no
what they mean is anyone who has had
anything to do with this
if they can find a facebook post that
you said you went to a rally or you
voted for trump or anything else
we should remove you and then you
shouldn't i guess be allowed to work at
a college
uh you shouldn't be able to work at an
entertainment organization or a news
organization
now of course the irony here is and this
is this is the hypocrisy of these sort
of never trump conservatives
is that she's making sure that she has a
job right so she's
she's their their lap dog um while at
the same time
she thinks that will save her but
eventually it'll come for you too like
you're you're just a willful idiot um
but it's not just that trump has to lose
but all his
enablers have to lose and and the really
deranged part
if there are any people who weather this
storm they will do it again sorry i want
to jump to the sentence before that we
have to
level them because if there are
survivors
if there are people who weather this
storm they will do it again
if there are survivors i thought we're
healing ourselves guys
aren't we healing right now um this is
this is such
dangerous stuff now i get it that she's
just sort of a media construct and
nobody really listens to her and
you know bought twitter followers and
bots love her and the media whatever
because she's a
she's a deranged anti-trumper i i get
all that stuff i get all that but that
level of language
survivors if there are any survivors
saying we're they're trying right now
what they want you to think
is that if you voted your conscience
if you did something different than they
wanted you to do that they have a right
to destroy you and what they're telling
you is
there's i mean think about it within
just days within just
days of the result
they're already saying we've got lists
we're going to destroy
people you won't be invited to polite
society
they're trying to fear to make you
afraid of your
own shadow and you know what
i think there's nothing to fear but fear
itself i really think so i really think
so i have no doubt that there's a lot of
people who would love to destroy me
and they are not particularly good
people but should i either live my life
in fear of those people or should i do
what i think is right
and then see where the chips fall i
think it's obvious
for me at least that i'm gonna do the
latter but all of th they want you to
feel
fearful right now they want you to say
you will never win again
and go back crawl under that rock that
you came from
and to say that to 70 million people 70
million people who are who are proud
americans who are not racists
and who have a lot of guns by the way
probably not the best thing to say so
so it is an odd situation because on one
hand you've got a set of them saying
we have to heal we have to heal the
nation right
and then on the other hand you have this
set that are saying but we must destroy
these people and
i'm not even sure which one of them is
more disingenuous when they're when
they're saying it
it's it's uh it's pretty wacky okay guys
uh
we are doing live dms every day this
week uh i'm actually
uh headed to dallas i'm going to be
doing some stuff with the blaze so one
of our dm's at least on thursday will be
live from
the dallas studios i have not left los
angeles since this freaking
lockdown began so i will get on a plane
i i assume
that it's still the same can you get
peanuts anymore or i guess peanuts were
taken out like 20 years ago for
allergies but
oliver soda i guess you can episode i
don't know um
and and there'll be just a lot of stuff
continuing to happen
so don't lose your head don't burn down
the city i know you won't
and i think everything's going to be
okay we'll figure it out let's continue
and if you want to talk to me directly
join us at reubenreport.com
have a great monday everybody